today's topic uh megan the stallion
so if you aren't aware megan stallion is
a music artist very popular right now
and she had an incident where she was uh
details weren't clear but apparently she
got shot in the foot was his feet
both her feet or just her foot she got
shot in the foot
she was at the time she was called a
foot soldier
at the time she was with tory lanez
who's a canadian music rap artist
and all the details surrounding the
incident were pretty murky until
recently
megan stelling got an ig live and
claimed that tory lanez
shot her in the foot and
the reason why she never said it before
for weeks on end was because she was
covering she didn't want to get the
police involved and all that stuff but
apparently tory lanez's people
had come out and started saying that
megan was hitting him trying to flip the
story around before making could tell
the truth
so all this blew up megan told the world
that he shot her in the foot
as she was walking away from the car
now people are calling her a snitch for
turning on tory and getting the
authorities involved
and that's where we're at it's a good
summary good summary
okay your summaries are already good
y'all can't be like yo black lives
matter
y'all can't be saying all this stuff
about police is killing us
and then when one of your own people get
shot by one of your own you'd be like
yeah you can't handle that problem
what did you want to what did what were
her alternatives cause some goons and
take care of it that way
then she goes to jail and then her she
can't of course
what are the recourses you have to go to
the justice system even if it isn't just
and it's got its problems
she should be going that route so no i'm
not don't miss me with that nonsense i'm
not gonna sit here and defend a man who
shot somebody
in the foot because she wanted to get it
out of the car yo she was walking away
you shot her in her feet [ __ ] it's the
thumbnail what are we talking about
that is the thumbnail what justifies
that tory lanez
canadian we got gun control
but we don't miss
oh you stupid for that one but i ain't
mad at you he's canadian right yeah he's
canadian
yo he's canadian you know he's short as
[ __ ]
yeah he's a hot head he's a munchkin
yeah he
that napoleon uh complex thing
apparently napoleon's not short i know
but okay yeah but like the whole like
short temper yeah bro you know there's
so many videos of him running up on
people
trying to add gangster he's goofing down
and here's another thing
men in their [ __ ] fragile ego
sometimes like yo
what is you that you have to have a
fragile ego to be in an argument with
somebody shoot someone because they want
to get out of the [ __ ]
they're walking away and you shoot them
only a fragile ego can justify that
shooting someone in the feet after that
you try to you try to tarnish your image
and you say and you call this no that's
some fragile and look
i've seen i've seen dudes fight for
weightless okay i have seen
it i've seen it so many times oh [ __ ]
you step on my air foot
okay how many times have we heard that
that was a running joke don't step on
the [ __ ] air forces yeah
yeah you don't step on someone's voice
just yo listen and now you're what you
potentially ruined your life
for what shooting her in the foot for
what
what are you doing with a gun you're
canadian no what are you doing with a
gun
you're famous you got bodyguards
it's like the baby when you [ __ ] slap
that bra you got people you paid for
that
these guys are goofy man because they
want to act hard and they got ego
stop stop that yeah man listen there's
so many things so stupid with this
incident
her trying to protect him i get that's
how she was raising all that stuff
stop uh this cannot be considered
snitching because she's not part of a
gang she's not even about that life
that gang gang stuff or whatever what
not she's not in the gang she's a
civilian
she got the snitch something bad
happened to a black woman she has to
something has to happen to her
we can't just hide it because oh no man
there's a hood we just no
that's not she didn't snitch she didn't
snitch
she got shot she didn't even fish to the
police
it's just people that shot her and the
entourage of the people that shot her
was trying to change the whole story to
make her look bad
and i ain't about that snitch if you
call it snitching
go ahead just tell the truth because
they were trying to [ __ ]
they were trying to tarnish her image
they were trying when she's the one that
got shot
they were trying to go at her and just
[ __ ] when i got shot
now that's what i understand to happen
i don't have all the information and on
this one i'll wait but from what i see
that's what it is well there's
justifiable snitching which i wouldn't
even call snitching
you know what i'm saying like i don't
understand like let's say you're getting
beat by your husband
and he's beating you every day and you
call the cops oh you're a snitch
uh no you you're going against someone
who's your abuser
you're a woman that gets beat yeah stop
protecting the people who are hurting
you
say that again that's it stop protecting
the people that are hurting you whether
it's in your neighborhoods and you know
someone who's beating up the women in
the street
whatever it might be if you see that
kind of stuff don't be out there
protecting these kind of people
not saying you necessarily have to be
the one to go out to snitch if it wasn't
your incident but
listen if you shoot me in the foot
that's going to the cops
what am i going to do what are the
alternatives i'm going to fight you
maybe end up potentially dead
may end up killing you then i go to jail
who's going to take care of my mom my
family
i'm like what are we even talking about
i'm gonna fight you [ __ ] you got a gun
i'm not fighting you
you got a whole gun something this is
crazy out here all right but all this to
say
that i think that's the saddest thing
the fact that she thought she should
protect him
to me but i don't think that this goes
out to not only the people living on the
street
goes out to your family yeah sometimes
it's hard
but yeah yeah so that that was my
thoughts when i uh when i heard this
stuff and
and yeah man guys stop fighting over
nonsense
yeah you're angry right now it's gonna
blow over your pride is not that
important people about to throw away
their whole lives
not be present in their kids lives throw
away generational wealth
throw away the opportunity to be part of
their communities because they have
some pride and they need to flex their
ego what a waste of time
so i think like that's just the saddest
part someone was hurt
someone may have ruined their life and
for what
so yeah that's pretty much all i got let
us know what you guys think in the
comments below one last thing
if you get famous get counseling
[Music]
i was in the military and i snitched on
someone yeah but that's because you
would snitch
yo i think it was crazy though damn okay
we were doing basic training
okay this tall lurch-looking ass [ __ ]
okay this guy's tall his name was
charles okay talk like he was from
england grew up in nova scotia didn't
understand nothing was wrong
weird guy he would just walk around
and people would have these weird
run-ins with this dude and we were 60
people in a platoon tight space
and one day apparently somebody like
threw his laundry load out of the
laundry
didn't get finished so he's mad and he
said oh yeah
okay that's what you guys are gonna do
with this whole group of us just sitting
down so
wait till you guys fall asleep i was
like excuse me no that's not snitching
hold up
i said what she said wait till you guys
fall asleep
i said this [ __ ] crazy he's like oh
we're going to the range next week right
we're getting live rounds huh good i was
like
i didn't just snitch bro i made it
official i drafted a memo
i had had the other had the other
platoon members sign it
we took it to the guy he got taken off
the course i said i'm not going to no
firing range with rifles and this man is
making threats and he's going to be like